my name is Peter uh Peter vdos I'm from
Hungary I traveled here representing uh
our startup that we built there called
vizu and uh as you will soon enough
learn we're into animated data
visualization uh we have a technology
that we built from the ground up and and
I've been traveling into these
conferences for some time now I have the
luck of being invited to to show what we
do uh but this is the first time that I
actually have the chance to share the
stage with somebody else so as things go
we we had some time uh with our tool and
then actually last year I was here at P
New York and I managed to get in touch
with Katrina real who was the head of
data at stream L at the time and she got
excited about what we do and she
introduced me to none other than Zachary
Blackwood and he created yeah I think of
he he deserves a big round of applause
even without knowing what he did so uh
he actually created an integration of
streamlit of wizu into s streamlit and
uh when I got to know that he's coming
to this conference I was very keen on on
having him with me on stage so um for
today our goal is uh for you to have fun
and to get your hands dirty so uh if you
want to participate you would definitely
need a laptop or a team of people around
you from which at least one of you
should have a laptop with internet
access there was uh some sort of a
description on the yeah on the on the
schedule about what you need to install
in order to participate uh how many of
you have read this in this installation
instructions oh wow five people okay
yeah no I mean that's that's more than I
expected and and that guy over there is
cheating because I already uh run over
their crew and started asking questions
whether they check the the tech intro
part okay that so the first part will be
quite frontal we tell you what we're
dealing with and how it works and give
you a lot of examples on on the
possibilities and then the second part
will be individual teamwork and
hopefully we will have some time at
towards the end where some of you would
just share their apps with us their
streamlet apps and then we can just show
them on stage and discuss uh how how
they were done we prepped with some uh
sample data sets as well but you can you
will be also able to use your own um but
first things first I mean no this is the
first things second I don't know I'm I'm
not a native speaker anyhow I would love
to get to know you a little bit so uh
like how many of you are data scientists
hands up okay roughly I don't know 20%
data
Engineers okay another 20 python
developers um everybody else okay who
hasn't had their hand up in the last
three
questions okay we H you can you tell me
what what do you do I mean I'm just
curious like um I currently work in
audit so not data related at all but
okay M ah cool I'm so glad to be that
you're here okay uh have any of you ever
used streamlit hands up M roughly 30%
maybe okay people have their hands up
and then put it down I'm not sure uh
have you ever used vizu
no hard feelings here so uh nobody okay
that's basically the answer that I
expected so let's start with what visu
is one one other thing I uh during the
session I would want to make some photos
and videos of you working on it and and
ourselves is there anybody who has some
issues with
that perfect okay so what is vzu let's
start with that part um vizu is
basically so what we created is an
engine that uses a single logic to
generate all different types of charts
and because of this uh aspect this
approach that we embedded into our
engine it can also interpolate between
these charts that are expressed on its
interface it's as simple as that it's a
generic chart Morpher and uh we we have
like you know next logical question why
would someone build uh generic chart
Morpher so we we have a vision that
we're working towards as I said we are
still an early stage startup and this
slide shows what vision is it's
basically we try to teach uh let people
work data in a much more visual fashion
than they do right now this is like this
vision is more about General business
people rather than experts like yourself
we would want them to be able to explore
analyze their data visually and then
turn them into animated data stories
right away reuse them on reports and
dashboards and maybe also for um for
forecasting and plan planning so that's
that's a big plan we we've been in
operation for some time we managed to
close our our preed funding round
earlier this summer so if everything
goes well uh there should be a tool
coming out a point and click tool
without any coding interface uh for
basic business users early next year uh
and uh so why is animation important
that might be the next logical question
yeah like first we yeah so static static
charts are pretty abstract when you have
uh different use of the same data set
like in this case these are about Donald
Trump's tweets but that's not important
uh so uh it might be hard to make the
connection between them it might be hard
to understand uh what one shows after
the other especially for non-experts
whereas if I connect these views with
animation um everything becomes really
clear no further explanation is
necessary and um and that's that's
really cool and there's a lot of uh you
know brain resources to to to save uh
when when you want to get somebody
involved when you want to share their
insights for example and uh based on all
the surveys that we gathered so far uh
people like you spend roughly half the
time explaining what is on a chart and
just the other half explaining why it
matters so this way it can save U
something on that side uh a couple of
examples so you can drill down using
animation when you have a complex
Composite Index and you want to show the
components of it and and their relation
uh you can um also uh just you know show
the part to whole relation and and make
it really easy to understand when
there's a component that goes against
the trend uh you can uh switch from uh
aggregate view to distribution over time
for example in a very easy to follow
fashion um you can obviously uh show
change over time using for example
um a chart like this uh a racing bar
chart that were so popular in the recent
years that they've been banned from the
dat's beautiful subredit at certain
point in time uh and um yeah so and and
you can actually turn one chart into a
whole story like a pie chart that if you
add something on the y- axis will turn
into a story showing how much money
different companies uh producing mobile
phones made over the years and uh just
from the single pie chart we get to the
understanding of having these leagues of
companies making totally different
amounts of Revenue uh from basically
producing and selling the same product
or the same type of product at least so
uh something about our technology the
core engine this data morphing engine is
in C++ we're using web assembly to
compile it in the browser uh after we uh
raised our initial funding round we
released a tool for JavaScript
developers back in 2021 and that's when
we turned our attention towards data
scientists the first will be released
over like almost 18 months ago no over
18 months ago called IPI visu and uh
that ran in Jupiter notebook and similar
computational notebooks and then we
added a little extension that enabled uh
people to build present and share
animated data stories right within a a
notebook a Jupiter notebook or a similar
one we have a ton of Integrations all
that we do this so far is open source
and free and thus we get contributions
like the ones you can see on the screen
uh like these most of them were done by
by others than than our core team which
was three people at the time and only
one of us are a coder and it's not me so
uh if you have deeply technological
questions Zachary is a much better
person to talk about talk with and if
you have deeply technical questions
about vzu I'll try my best okay um but
uh yeah so that's about it and let's
turn to I mean I I'll show you how the
whole thing works and then I'll give the
floor to uh Zachary to to show what
streamlet is uh actually everything that
we prepped for you can be reached if
you're following this bitly link so bit.
lstream lore Vore NYC oh yeah sure I
also have it in a QR code format so you
can use that if that's easier for
you uh you will end up in a repo folder
that uh that yeah that that has
everything that you will need um okay
and let's start let's continue with oh I
forgot to do
this um so I wanted to show first like
what you will be able to build towards
the end of this session this is a
streamlet app with a visual chart in it
it shows how much revenue different
music form has generated over the year
in the US and the user here can just uh
set the time frame differently and can
also just uh switch from uh from from
revenue to volume or uh you can
aggregate uh the data by format instead
of by year uh add more formats to the
Chart like this and then sort it by
value which is pretty cool uh and there
are a ton of other views that you can
generate using this interactive report
but also it gets saved in the background
and I told you about IPI vis a story so
this is the kind of story that I just
download here as as an HTML file and
open it up in my browser and it
basically contains all the views that I
generated and I can just scroll through
them using a clicker so every step that
I took while I was using uh the the the
report there was got preserved like when
I was switching over from revenue to
volume and then I accumulated everything
by format instead of by year so
basically you can build apps in
streamlit using vizu that would enable
anyone without any coding expertise to
build an animate and present animated
data stories like the one that you can
see on screen so that's the goal we're
working towards yeah sorry I forgot that
and yeah the rearrangement part so um
yeah how does ipiv Vis Works um it I I'm
going to show you a quick example in a
notebook just to get a sense of the
logic that we employ and good news you
don't have to learn it we built an app
for you that does most of the heavy
lifting of using this of employing this
new logic and and using IPI visu syntax
or visu syntax okay but I think it still
makes sense to get some understanding of
how our tool works so I would just
really quickly go through it in a
jupyter notebook that's on the screen we
have a single method called the animate
method you call it once it gets to you a
static chart you call it once again that
chart will morph into another chart and
you have the opportunity to give a data
to your chart set the configuration uh
set the styling of the chart and you can
also fiddle with the animation options
like how the animation happens uh you
can install it using paper Honda it's uh
integrated with a pandas data frame and
here in this example I'm going to use
the Titanic data just as an example and
I create an empty chart here uh this is
again not something you have to remember
anything uh this is a jupyter notebook I
just hacked the CSS a little bit so the
output appears next to the cell so you
can see the code and the and the output
right next to each other and so the
first animate method is U I'm just
adding the counts so the number of
passengers on the x-axis the sex on the
y-axis
and also the number of passengers on the
label and we get a bar chart okay it's
easy as that now what I do is I call the
animate method once again and I add the
survived category whether that passenger
survived the crash or died uh on the
x-axis and also on the color and I end
up with a stacked bar chart like this
and if I remove uh the surviv category
from the x-axis and add it to the y-axis
then it gets into a group D chart easy
as that uh you you have a ton of options
to play with like for example the data
part it lets you filter the data that is
shown right I'm going to filter to only
people who traveled first class to see
how how this chart looks to them and as
you can see it happens also in an
animated fashion I just reren the cell I
can uh use circles instead of rectangles
for geometric elements and when I do I
can add the same value on the size of
the markers and and I can switch from um
like ukian coordinates to Polar and I'll
end up with a chart that no one
understands so uh it's yeah like that's
what happens when you have a generic
chart Morpher that employs a generic
logic you can actually build charts that
are hard to understand even though they
employ the logic of every chart that is
out there and yes you can also play with
the styling so I here I'm just going to
St that the markers should have a
different color pette for example and
like the diet turns out red and the
Servite green and yeah that's about it
so there are a ton of options like this
and again the good news you don't have
to learn how they work you just have to
understand the logic of it and so
without further Ado I'll give the floor
to Zachary so that he can let us know
how this whole how what streamlit does
uh there you go all
right uh I'm Zachary Blackwood and I uh
came to work at streamlet when uh a
couple years ago and then we got
acquired by Snowflake and my favorite
part of my job is I get to build lots of
streamlet apps and I get to build those
uh for use for internal stakeholders and
I get to help other people on the on
other data teams across snowflake build
those and I get to work with some open
source things like vizu so uh it's a lot
of fun and I want to tell you date about
streamlet some of you this is you uh a
good chunk of you have have used stream
before that's exciting to see but I want
to give at least a quick overview if any
for those of you that are unfamiliar
with it so there's a classic problem
which is you got the data and you know
how to do an analytics but you want to
have a way to share it with your with
your stakeholders you want you want a
way to be able to communicate uh
communicate from the data and and create
something that you can actually give to
a non-technical person you can actually
give to a business uh leader someone who
actually make decisions and so streamlet
is a really great solution for that it's
it's really just a generic app building
framework so you can take some python
code and it builds you a web app um
really it's really focused around data
but people use it for all all kinds of
crazy things um the the the gist of
streamlet is you write a python script
and you run it with this streamlet run
command and then it spits out something
like this on the right and it really is
um you know as you can see a relatively
small amount of code to produce a pretty
nice looking app we have great designers
uh and at least I I'm not a designer but
I think they look pretty good um and
it's very easy to iterate on it's very
easy to it's very easy to tweak things
and play with it um one of the my
favorite things about stream apps is
they're they're interactive by default
you have all these different kinds of
widgets um like you would with with many
dashboard kind of building app building
tools so you got sliders and date
Pickers and all those things um you can
do some some basic theming uh we're
actually trying to figure out how to
expand that a little bit and not let
people make too horrible of uh theming
decisions on that in the future but you
got some basic options on that and
because it's uh it's all in Python you
can pretty much use uh any python
library that you want to um in terms of
the the output of that if there's visual
output we'll get I'll get to that a
little bit later but in terms of behind
the scenes it's just a python script it
just runs your python script and
whatever you can do in a python script
you can do in a streamlet app um so the
basic gist of how do you write a stream
app is well again it's a script it runs
from top to bottom and if you have if
your mental model is it runs from top to
bottom it'll work really well um it's
actually that's you know it is really
how it works and whenever you interact
it runs again um and the widgets those
those date Pickers and and checkboxes
and buttons all those interactive pieces
you can think of those as just the
output of variable and that variable has
whatever the value is so if it's a
checkbox it's either it's a Boolean
value if it's a SL I get a I get an
integer date or whatever kind of thing
you're sliding
across um and uh you know some of you
already thinking oh I don't want to
rerun my app every time well one of the
things you that is built in from the
early early ages of streamlet is you can
choose which parts you want to not rerun
and to Cache um so you can reuse those
values over and over again um and not
have to do the expensive part so starts
out with a really uh really something
basic like stright which is which is a
generic way to say put this on the
screen takes markdown or pandas data
frames or all kinds of other things um
and then you could you have basic
plotting tools like st. line chart and
other other ones like that you can see
these widgets like x equals St dos
slider so then for the rest of the the
rest of the time you don't have to think
oh there's some complicated feedback
mechanism going on X is whatever the
slider is and that's just that's just
how it works and you just move on down
you don't have to think in terms of okay
there's actually a call back that's
going to make this change into this
which is going to feed into this you
just think okay X is going to have the
value of the slider and wherever I use x
whatever the slider was that's what x is
um and then there's these built-in uh
there's built-in uh methods called Cash
data and cache resource cache resource
being there's a thing I create once and
I want to reuse it for a long time or if
um or there's some data that I want to
compute where maybe I pass a variable
into it and if as long as that variable
doesn't change I don't want to rerun
this computation I'm quering a database
or I'm pulling I'm pulling data from an
API um I don't want to do that over and
over again and so these cache methods
are built in for that all these slides
um are U there's a there's a link if you
didn't get the we'll put the bitly link
up again these slides are available on
that by the way um so all these sort of
sort of interactive interactive things
you can you know do fancy things like
like uh have you know use the webcam and
things like that as well as basic things
like upload a file or click a button and
there's all kinds of different widgets
and the docs are great if you just go to
docs. stream.io uh you'll find all about
all these things so that example I put
up earlier with uh with some where
showed a table and showed a line chart
this is basically what it comes down to
first thing you do is you load the data
and this shows the example of how you do
that with caching so this this uses st.
cach data to say that I always want to
return once I I'm going to fetch it the
first time and then for and then it's
going to cash it in memory and the rest
of the time and just going to reload the
cach one so it's if it's a very slow if
it's a very big file you'll load it once
and then it'll be fast after that and
it'll just return the cache data frame
you can control things like TTL how long
do you want to go before the cache gets
cleared um things like that and then
once you've got your data you've got a
panda data frame or really any kind of
you know any kind of uh any kind of data
format um then you
uh add some widgets so for example here
you want to filter down to particular
kinds of countries this this uh multi-
select let you pick different options
and you can X them out or select them uh
and then you can use those and so this
is just this is just some you know some
pandas manipulation you take it and you
you filter down to just those ones and
then you do sd. write to put a nice some
text and then you do SD data frame it
puts a data frame and then you do some
Transformations um and then you end up
with uh end up with a chart like this in
this case we're not using the St the
built-in streamlet charting we're using
Al a you can use uh one of any number of
charting libraries including theu that
we'll get to in a little bit uh uh but
but most any any kind of charting
Library you can think of probably is is
is pretty well supported in streamlet
and there's your full top to bottom
script that's not too many lines to get
a pretty nice looking pretty nice
looking app that you're ready to share
with your stakeholders
um there's all kinds of more detailed
things like you can control the layout
uh often times you would just make a
simple app that's just top to bottom as
as you want wrot you want to split
things up between different columns for
example things like that or you want to
have even multiple Pages for your app so
you can have a sidebar where you select
different pages um and there's all kinds
of thirdparty components that I'll get
I'll talk a little bit in just a minute
about those um this example shows the
way you can just set up your you set up
your repo you set up a folder that has
an
app.py that's your main that's your
first page and then everything that's in
Pages all the python files that are in
the pages folder just become pages on
your app and so that you'll see in this
example on the sidebar there there's
your this it builds this for you just
based on whatever is in the pages folder
um and yeah there's a we've we've uh
it's been fun to to be uh working at
streamlet when uh lots of people wanted
to build really quickly and really
easily build uh llm apps and uh stream
is a pretty is a pretty fun way to do
that we we relatively recently added
these built these uh Native chat widgets
so if you haven't used it in a while
these might look unfamiliar but um but
it lets you it lets you very easily
build a a a chat a chat kind of chat
Style app where you have messages back
and forth and you have a chat input at
the bottom and you don't just have text
but you can have charts and things um as
part of the messages uh so it's pretty
nice for that there's lots of people
have been using these to build lots of
different lots of different uh AI
powered apps as you might as you might
guess uh so there's all kinds of fun
examples um this is the one that picture
on the right is from um is from our home
on the on the website you can look at
see different examples and different
categories that people have made of
different apps so uh lots of lots of
Integrations there um again it's python
so you can probably pretty much use it
but a lot of these we've really worked
to make sure they they work well we've
led a lot with Partners from these
companies
um uh the docs are great the forum's
great I personally spend uh some time
most days on the Forum I'm kind of
slacking this week um but it's a great
place to go and just find lots of lots
of answers to lots of different
questions that people have um the doc
are
delightful uh and people are building
lots of apps and it's it's really fun to
see the new exciting things that people
built a lot of them are kind of the
straightforward things that you expect
and then sometimes people build a
Dungeon Crawler in streamlet which is
not really what streamlet is made for
but you know why not uh it's all kinds
of beautiful ones um encourage you to
check it out uh the other thing that
that streamlet does we've had for a good
while is we host your apps for free if
you have a public GitHub repo um you get
a free uh we we'll give you we'll host
it and run it run it for free and as
long as you know you have limited amount
of r and dis needs should work just
great so we have many thousands of many
thousands of apps that are on there and
it's all free and there's not even a
paid version of it you just you just uh
get what you get and it's a few clicks
and wait a little bit for the fun food
animations to finish and then you've got
your app and you can share it share it
with
people uh if you never use streamlet
this is how you start we'll talk more
about this when we get to the Hands-On
bit but essentially pip and soul
streamlet should just work uh you know
we recommend a virtual environment and
all that all that good stuff stuff you
can use pip foronda uh and there's even
a way to there's a built-in way to do it
with code spaces so you don't have to
install anything but if you have
installed it locally run streamlet hello
and you get this nice little welcome app
um I want to talk about components
because because one the basic the reason
I'm here is because I worked on this
component uh with Peter and others at at
vizu um so one of the so the stream core
team is building lots of functionality
and lots of things built into streamlet
itself but there's a whole world out
there of other things and and there are
other libraries and tools that aren't
baked into streamlet and so there's this
there's this big question of okay I have
my streamlet app and I want to use this
thing that doesn't doesn't work with it
natively well some of it just does work
natively so you might just try it um
there's a lot of things that like for
example if it works in a Jupiter
notebook there's a decent chance that
some version of it will work in your
streamlet app as well um uh but there's
also cases where that doesn't work um or
sometimes you can just if you have just
some HTML
you can just embed it directly and that
sometimes works okay but a lot of
sometimes you want a little bit more of
a native feel and Native control and so
that's what the component system is for
so stream has had this ability to create
components which are these which are
which feel a lot like they were built
into stream but they're actually made by
third third party developers um and this
is what uh I I'm going to talk about and
you're going to see with with vizu where
built some custom wrote some custom code
released it on pii and now people can
install it to to work with vizu more
natively in
streamlet um there's a bunch of
components out there there's a there's a
there's a section on the website uh
stream.io components I believe is the
URL that'll show you some of the really
popular ones there's a lot out there
there's a couple that I've uh helped
with um and if if you have some
expertise and you have a python library
or a JavaScript library that you find
doesn't work I'd encourage you to make a
component for it and uh and release it
and I even wrote a blog post about one
way to do that um that you can see on
there um so stream with vizu there are
as you saw there was this already this
amazing C++ Library even better there's
a JavaScript library and there's a
python library to interface with it and
it worked pretty well in notebooks
already it didn't quite work natively in
streamlet you couldn't do things like
well you'll see later you couldn't click
on a chart and get data out of it and
use that to update other parts of your
app so uh I thought what if we could
just hijack what it already does and
build a component on top of that so so
in reality yeah I wrot I made the
component for this um but really it was
mostly working on the building on the
work that had already been done and just
hacking around until it worked so I'd
actually already done this with another
with a friend uh on another component
called folium folium is is a similar
tool and that it there's there's a it's
based on leaflet which is in JavaScript
somebody wrote a python uh wrapper
around that and so I hacked into it to
make it work in streamlet so and that's
what you'll see today with streamlet
visu as well it takes the the underlying
work of I vizu which is designed to work
in notebooks and add some add some new
abilities and that so that you can get
bidirectional feedback it can the the
app can talk to the uh talk to the chart
to update it and the chart can talk back
to the app um to change other things and
that's about
streamline uh we'll have time maybe for
questions later I think yeah absolutely
absolutely okay so uh the next bit is
about showing you an app that has
streamlit visu in it um and and show you
the code right next to it so these apps
serve two purposes first of all they are
basically a step-by-step tutorial so we
start simple and then it gets
complicated
and then for the sort of individual work
uh you have the code there so feel free
to copy and paste everything and reuse
it on your own data and you know add
some more functionality so it's also
kind of like inspiration and code to
copy from uh that are very
straightforward in in their
functionality uh and um so basically
this is how uh this a streamlet app that
has visu in it looks like it's it's just
a single python file uh similarly to a
notebook we need to import some
components here it's not IPI Vu but
streamlit Vu but it basically has the
same objects that we had in in IPI visu
so config data style and visu chart
instead of chart and initially we just
create a a simple chart here uh we we
create a very sophisticated data frame
with uh uh one categorical and and one
numerical series all both containing
three values XY Z and 1 2 3 we uh create
an empty data object of uh IPI visu or
or streamlet visu and then we call the
add DF method of that data object in
order to add the data frame uh to the
data object and then we add the data
object to the chart by calling chart
animate data that creates an empty chart
with the data already loaded and then
what we do here is we basically animate
again calling the animate method with
the configuration of X being on uh so
the category being on the x-axis and the
value being on the y y axis and a title
look at my plot and that's the result of
this animate method that you can see on
the screen now we also have a checkbox
here uh with a conditional uh that if
the checkbox is uh checked then the
chart should animate to the state where
actually it's uh the value on the x-axis
instead of on the y axis and the
category on the y-axis instead of the
x-axis so if I click on Swap the chart
is going to swap uh yeah let me just
zoom out a bit here so you can see the
whole chart do so um yeah I can I can
swap back and forth very basic very
understandable first app okay uh you can
also click on any of the elements and
under it this is what the B
directionality that Zachary was
referring to it writes the value of the
click bar under it so you get data out
of it I'll show you a more sophistic at
example right away now uh let's use a
different um interactive element uh of
of of streamlit the slider here so
here's the again the music data how much
revenue different music format generated
over time and uh I put the year on the
slider and if I change the year then the
values on shown on the chart change uh
to show only uh the revenue that was
that was generated in that particular
year and and the uh the the chart so the
items on the charts are uh are ordered
by value so as you can imagine it
changes over time as it's basically a
racing chart racing bar chart you can
control with this slider and uh the the
code for this I mean the first part is
basically the same we just read a CSV
file that's a panas feature you I'm
pretty sure you're all familiar with
here we add a key and we set the height
of the visu chart that's also very
straightforward add the data to it and
we turn on the tool dip feature this is
that if you move your mouse over the
chart it will show you the value uh
represented by the underlying chart
element and then we add the slider like
this so we create the year variable and
we set it that it's uh should have the
value set by the slider uh we set the
minimum value and the maximum value and
the default value in one line of code
it's easy as that and then uh so what we
do here is we call the animate method
with the data filter on where it says
that uh the year should be oh this
should be actually equals equals and not
less than equal because then it sums up
all the values and you see I changed the
code and rerun it like that so this is
all run locally but basically so if I
change it back and then streamly tells
me that the underlying code changed so
you can see source file changed over
there and if I rerun the code then we
animate to the new the the updated app
easy as that so it's actually not music
revenue is in but music revenu is up to
and if I save that and rerun we will
change the title easy as that and yeah
here we also set the The Styling a
little bit so we had a color pallet and
and the and and and a number scale so
that the numbers look nicer except for
when they are on the tool tip um sorry
about that we're an early stage start
start up as I said uh and we set also
the animation option the delay down to
zero uh initially when you call the
animate method there's like a 1 second
delay before the animation starts so
that it's easier to follow along after
you click on a button for example but
here I just want everything to be
smoother so I want the animation to
start right away and I set it by uh
setting the delay to zero and uh yeah so
that's that's how you add the slider to
a chart let me show you one example
where uh we employ the bir
directionality of the component so
basically once again music data you see
the total values for each here on the
chart now and uh right now if I click on
any of the columns here uh we are just
going to zoom in and then drill down and
split it up like that and if I click on
anywhere else we get back to the
original view so again if I move my
mouse over click on any of the bars we
zoom in we drill down we group and then
we have the details and so the way to do
it is we basically so this was built by
Zachary we do everything the same up to
uh here basically so what we there there
is a bar clicked variable which gets uh
the year category from the marker that
has been clicked so the just one
variable year and uh if bar click this
none then we have the animate the data
filter should be empty and then you know
year is on the x-axis revenue is on the
y- axis color is empty whatever but if
we have something on the within inar
clicked then we should employ a filter
where the year equals to Bar clicked and
uh the revenue is not zero now this part
I added just last night because uh let
me just remove it and you'll see what it
means so if I zoom in now uh I will have
all the different music formats even the
ones that have zero value for that year
and that's I mean it it looks nicer if
we if we have it like this I just undo
the changes save the file once again and
then I'll only have yeah you see it
updated instantly I'll only have the
values uh that that are different than
zero and that's it so you have an
interactive animated chart where people
can just click on values and zoom in and
drill down that's pretty cool right and
the whole thing is like 68 lines of code
uh okay the last example I want to show
you the code of and then for the all the
others you would have the chance to
explore on your own is uh kind of like
an Explorer like basically a chart which
we put a lot of controls around uh to
let you uh just fiddle with I mean let
the user of the app fiddle with what's
on the chart exactly it's some madeup
sales data uh so it's not really
important it's from a company that sells
stuff and and generates revenue from
different products in different regions
I mean I'm pretty sure most of you had
some experience with the excitement of
this uh so basically now we see the
sales so the number of items of per
product in a cartisian coordinate system
arranged or sorted alphabetically but I
can change it to show the revenue
instead of the the number of items uh
show product and region both like then
uh the the regions will be added on the
color or just region and then it will
morph to column chart aggregating all
the revenue that was generated per uh
per region I can uh just yeah order them
by value and and I can switch it to
Polar which again is not a chart we're
using to too often no wonder why but uh
it it shows you the capabilities of this
engine and uh yeah so in order to test
how to fiddle with the styling element
Zachary added this little Color Picker
so I can can turn the background color
of the chart very ugly here you go it is
indeed very ugly um let me try and get
it back to normal like white at least uh
this should do yeah all right so uh the
way this app works is that we have uh
added some multi select oh yeah we can
we can actually remove products this is
the one control that I haven't used it
has a list of items as you can see uh we
added some five columns into which we
added like a radio button that reads
measure and that has the option sales
and revenue and reads the value being
set here into a variable called measure
and so for all the five we did that and
what we do here is just basically we
have one animate method towards the very
end that calls data filter filter which
was set by actually this multi select
thingy the config that that only has
config here and and it's set like okay
so label should be measure y should be Y
and depending on different conditions
basically up in the app we set these so
if compare by is product then on the y-
AIS it should be the product and on the
x-axis it should be the measure which
could be either sales or revenue and
then on the color there should be
nothing if compare by is region then uh
the measure is on the y axis instead of
the X so it basically just changes so
this one sets what's on the X and what's
on the Y AIS based on the results of
these three radio buttons uh and uh so
as you can see we have these seven
different
controls uh here that all change what we
see there and all we need to do is is
combine them in order to have the end
result one configuration and one animate
method that basically reruns every time
you change something in the Stream L
controls so that's how you make an
interactive report or or a dashboard
okay so for all the other examples I
just don't want to show the codes to
save time you have all these in the in
the repo folder or in the there's
actually a different folder different
repo for the streamlit VIS intro but you
have a link for that so this is this is
the original thing that you saw this is
what the bit.ly link LED you to the Pata
NYC Workshop folder and here is uh where
you can see the tutorial app then the
other app that that Zachary will show
you in a jiffy and then here's the the
link to the uh repo folder the repo of
of this app that I've just been showing
to you and that I again I encourage you
to copy and steal from no just copy
There's No Stealing involved um yeah and
this uh so a couple of I already showed
you this one where it's it's another
Explorer but you have the opportunity to
download uh every view that you
generated as an interactive story you
can also build a dashboard so like
what's a dashboard it's one one uh app
with multiple charts right so you can
add more than one visu chart to an app
they can all react to the same controls
I have no idea where this is here um and
um so for example if I change the years
then the content of these charts change
too and that's all about that they they
show obviously a very like drilled down
or like very filtered aggregated views
the top three years and the share of
formats within the data being viewed and
for that it's just like I had to add
more charts and I also fiddled with the
the animation options so every actually
this chart changes first and then this
and then this and in order to do that I
just set the delay differently so one wa
for the other uh and then uh there's
also the opportunity to work with the
editable data frame that streamlet has
so for example uh there's like some
madeup data of uh what are these
Pokémons thank you very much so and I
can change the the value here in this
data frame that I can see whoops I wrote
something that's not even on the chart I
like I make it active and it can be seen
right now U I think the width is not set
properly but I can still zoom out a
little bit more and then yeah we'll see
the fourth bar it can it in in the other
example it will be set properly and so
this would let the user copy and paste
some data to it and and just fiddle with
it and yeah actually there's a more
advanc version this was all created by
Sebastian Flores a great guy he lives in
Chile he's the first person who
delivered speeches about vizu in Spanish
and uh and I just love to work with him
and and he integrated so he did this
example of integrating vizu with with
the editable data frame this is a more
complex version where uh you can add the
new columns to the data frame even so
the user can adds new columns and decide
whether they are values or categories
and uh yeah so but and and can change
the the the chart type that's being used
and uh yeah a lot of other stuff so u i
I would encourage you to take a look at
the code if you want to employ some sort
of functionality with the editable data
frame and now comes the surprise that we
prepared for you to make your life
easier using vizu we've been working on
it in the last two days especially
Zachary and David from our team I'm
eternally grateful for them because I
was just telling them that that this
feature and that feature and then uh
told them when it's not ready yet so I
would let uh Zachary take the honor and
show you how it
works all right so the idea with this
the ideal with this app is you upload
upload a CSV it's got you know some
tabular data uh I we included some
sample data just to make it easier if
you don't have any lying around uh one
of the first things you can do is you
can you know take a peek and see what
the data looks like and here's here's
where we got some music stuff and we can
add filters to the data so for example
maybe we really only care about certain
genres and so we're going to you're
going to filter those down you know we
don't you know whatever we don't care
about pop right um and the you know so
far you know we're just clicking buttons
But ultimately the goal is that this is
generating uh not one chart but in fact
is generating a whole series of charts
just to show you the kinds of charts
that you can make um from a data set
like this and for example you can select
a different uh second categorical
variable and if I hit update charts then
you can see all of those update to show
then what happens if you have these two
categorical variables um and you know
it's drawing a lot of charts so give it
a second um and with each one of these
you can then look and see the code
that's required so here's pulling the
data uh here's creating the visu chart
here's where you do the filtering and
here's where you do the config and then
you do chart. show
um and uh as a bonus feature which uh I
did not add but it's very cool you can
uh take pick a couple of these and if
you want to create a story where it
transitions from one of these to another
you can just pick a few and add them to
your Adam to your story and then this
this lovely uh uh ipai vizu story player
at the bottom here and as he said we
just built it for you so there may be
there may or may not be a bug there but
you can see here the transitions from
these from one chart to the next that we
did this and we can you can delete
delete them to clean it up you can
download the story and get the HTML file
that you can then share share with
somebody else that just has these um
that has those Transitions and those
different pieces of your story so zero
to lightning talk about your data in you
know in one app that's that's kind of
the goal uh the goal with this is is is
to show you what you can do and actually
be a useful a useful thing and and the
link to this this is live uh on running
on community Cloud today I think it's
called vizu Builder viuu builder.
stream.app if you want to try it out
again you know we're working on it up up
till pretty recently uh so it's the
world premiere uh and there there are
there are almost certainly bugs uh as
you could see um yeah I think that's
yeah uh and I think it's it's important
to note that there are a couple of goals
in this have the first one is to show
you that basically the chart types
depend on how many categories and how
many values you want to see on the chart
uh so by changing that uh let me change
back slide because you will see it
better uh the online version so if you
like here by default it adds one
category like genes and one value
popularity but you have the option to
add another category and another value
actually different chart types would be
generated on the number of different
series and to to get this uh really easy
for you you just have to decide what
should be on your chart and we will give
you all the options that we have for
chart types that are well known and can
be generated using visu okay and and the
other is to help you with generating
code uh for your apps for your notebooks
for your stories so all is here
obviously if you add more chart then
then it's just easier not to copy and
paste all of it but just maybe the the
animate part uh because you know that's
that's actually belong to that chart all
the other stuff is to set it up but we
created the code here so that you can
just copy and paste it to a new uh new
uh streamlet visu app or streamlet app
and then it's good to go you will you
will end up with this chart right away
uh and then thirdly we want to help you
build data stories I mean I would love
to see one of of you stand out uh
tomorrow and do a lightning talk with IP
Vis story I will definitely try to be
there and do it more my own but I would
love to help you out doing so and so
when you add a chart to a story and and
then it appears beneath uh the the list
of charts you also have the code for
that story you can just copy and paste
it to a notebook and Fiddle with it
within the notebook like add styling
elements and and re slides and whatnot
so again we just wanted to make it
really easy for you to get started
without having to learn this intricate
very abstract logic of our tool Okay
cool so uh we're actually approaching
the part where we would give the floor
to you or at least your laptops to you
uh there
are I think um yeah basically two things
before that first of all I always do a
selfie with the crowd because I have to
prove the guys back at home that I
actually made it to New York and uh and
and delivered this so if that's okay for
you I mean and and I'm I'm just so happy
that right now I'm together here with
with with Zachary so I V A Very
sophisticated selfie stick and we will
just stand there and try to make a
couple of photos if that's okay for you
and in the meantime you should start
thinking about who you want to be in the
same team with we strongly enage you not
I mean you can go alone and and do
everything and and build an app on your
own but as always I learning new stuff
is easier when you have someone to talk
with like why is that why this
doesn't work for example that's very
logical question and uh and we'll be
here to help you out throughout the
whole time but if you can do it with
somebody else that's even better so
maybe take a look around you and and see
who you would want to you know have this
OPP share this opportunity with while
you so
you're
[Applause]
corre
Ang
[Laughter]
Lear
Google okay can I have your attention
for another second can you can you look
around here and uh say vzu on the count
of three so one two three
vzu is it to is
it yeah thanks thank you very much how
many of you have not found a teammate
that would want to work in a
team okay looks like everybody is all
set then uh what I think you should do
uh so we we try to we try to just uh LT
it within the repo folders read me how
you could how you could start working so
first find someone to work with check
out and get through the installation
guide below uh there's an installation
guide there are actually two versions
for those with experience in Python and
local development and for those new to
python packages and local setup uh
obviously this letter this letter is is
easier you would just use code spaces uh
after setting up a a GitHub account and
a streamlink account you might want to
set up a separate GitHub account for
this because uh uh streamly asks
permission uh to read all your public
repositories and there are people who
don't really like that if you're one of
those just you know create a new GitHub
account just for
this um the bitly link yes
absolutely um there you
go so it's stream lore vizu
NYC
no it's just I mean yeah okay
uh can I uh switch back to
the does anybody need the repo okay so
uh once you're done with
installation Fork the repo of the
tutorial app just Fork the repo you'll
have all the code there uh you can I
mean um like Zary will show you how easy
it is to do it when when you're doing
the easy version and you want to use
code space
get some data there are sample data sets
within this repo folder in the data
folder okay there are some csws ready
for you to analyze and
visualize and uh create a new Pyon file
and reuse Snippets use the Builder app
to generate ipiv Vu code be creative and
then share your
app do you have any questions about what
I just
said okay I'll let uh so here's the
tutorial app uh yeah we should go to the
online version I
guess and then uh can you please show
people around here how to Fork it when
you're using the online version yeah let
me zoom in a
bit take closer look it's going to so if
you're if you want to use if you want to
use pip locally oronda locally that's
great uh if you'd rather not or you it's
something you have some issues with it
um streamlet Cloud recently added this
new feature where you can Fork an app
um I don't know 100% for sure if this
will work well since he's already forked
the app probably on his account but
we're going to try it anyway but so what
that will do is that will it will prompt
you to either sign into or create an
account and it will spin up a code
spaces instance for you where you have
uh the code editor basically vs code in
the browser um on the left and you have
and it'll open up it'll open up a
browser a little mini browser in inside
the editor on the right um and by the
way when you create a community Cloud
app it gives you this opportunity to to
customize the URL so it's you know
something related to your repo and then
some gobbledygook if you want and it's
not taken you can call it whatever you
want my cool data app. stream.app or
something um or you can just leave it
the way it is and then if you hit Fork
that will clone the repo it will create
a fork of the repo into your GitHub
account and then it will pop open in an
editor where you have without installing
anything locally you'll have um you'll
have a uh a ready too editor on the left
and after a few seconds it will open up
a a little preview of what your app will
look like on the right and you can just
edit it in there save it in there and
then it'll it'll already be there on
GitHub for
you so thanks to Microsoft for free code
spaces
minutes yeah and uh for the venue and
for the venue
for the free venue spaces in Virtual and
physical world if you have any issues uh
with with particularly getting your
everything setup so you can actually
create Vis uh create these stream apps
uh please raise your hand we'll be
walking around yeah and absolutely just
so we know how many of you are actually
planning to do this like try to build a
Streamlight app on their own right
now hey so there are some uh
cool just please let us know if we can
help you if we can help you figure out
just why the code works in the tutorial
app why it doesn't so it's it's okay not
to build something new it's okay to use
the opportunity to ask us in person to
give you a more detailed rerun of
everything we just said but it's also
we'd love to have you build your apps or
just a short data story with the builder
app we're we're here to help there are
no expectations uh we just want you to
have fun as I said in the beginning okay
so if you have any questions just throw
up your hand and we'll be there to help
[Applause]
you